what do you think about free college
should College be free
so I would say free college is not at
the top of my list of priorities but it
definitely should be for you in my
vision of a just
um just Society what is it that you tell
just to clarify is the Universal Health
Care up there yeah universal healthcare
is probably far higher in my priorities
than than free college I think right now
the way our system is built
when someone goes to college they're
given credentials they're given decree
they carry with them for the rest of
their life it gives them a chance to
join kind of a privileged part of the
labor market right it's not a zero-sum
game I don't want college-educated
people to think that
um non-college educated people are their
enemies and vice versa because a lot of
them are just ordinary Working Class
People trying to survive and they're in
different areas or in different sectors
um you know some of them are in nursing
sectors where they need a college degree
and and so on
but if you just make College tuition
free but you don't also make uh trades
skills and other things
um tuition free for someone to learn how
to become an electrician or a plumber or
whatever else then to some degree you're
privileging one sector of the labor
market over another
um so I would Advocate just if you're
going to make something like that free
you just have to make sure that you're
doing an egalitarian way and that one
the options the routes to college are
more more equal so
um you know there's more investment in
K-12 education so that more kids in
rough neighborhoods have the chance to
go to college and for those that choose
the trade route from from any any part
of the country that they're given the
skills and resources for vocational
um you know trainings and that those are
also free and it just feels like in
terms of order of operation I would just
start with K-12 education improving it
and and whatever else then
College after but I'm not opposed to it
so does that improving K-12 education
does that mean investing more into it is
it as simple as just increasing the
amount of money that's invested in the
in public education in general when it
comes to the public sector or any any
sphere that you're investing in uh
obviously it's not just as simple as
throwing money at a problem I do think
we have a lot of schools that are um
underfunded but we have other schools
that are adequately funded but the
conditions in which those schools are
like the neighborhoods they're in and
what's going on in society
um the problems are so deep that it's
impossible for just education to solve
everything and I think especially a lot
of liberals think that education should
be the Panacea invest in education
you'll help people if kids are living in
poverty if they go into school hungry or
whatever else like education's not gonna
give them
everything they need to to succeed so
sometimes we I think put too much weight
on on education
and of course you can Define education
more broadly which is like
the care
of the flourishing of the young mind
whatever that is yeah whatever you call
this earlier yeah a lot of it starts
with so New York City at least we do
have
um Universal Pre-K so from H3 onward you
you have the option for that I mean it's
important for kids socialization you
know their parents are now able to you
know know that they could go to work or
do something else and have their you
know have their kids taken care of
um there's a lot of measures like that
that we can do to to equalize things and
again
for Libertarians in the audience you
know some of this stuff is scary because
it's obviously more State involved State
involved in pre-K
State it's already very involved in K-12
more investment into State institutions
like um our our state universities and
in college but for me it's not a
question of State versus non-state it's
a question of
um you know good outcomes for for people
and it just happens to be that for
Working Class People
um
having the collective power to elect
representatives that will build a
broader safety net is in their interest
for upper middle class people for others
they can afford to pay for their own
provisioning either directly or through
like Obamacare like schemes where you
just get a subsidy and you pay the rest
yourself and whatever this is for really
the bottom 40 plus of the population
they really don't have any options so
they prioritize others things they end
up with with some sort of injury or
health problem or whatever else and it's
it's bad for everyone in society but
especially bad for the people at the
bottom of the the labor market